ça fait 20 ans que la lune a été touchée
il ya d'électricité d'une heure par jour
à peine de quoi manger tout ce qui vous
intéresse elle que ce mot vol
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attention téléportation mélanger
son pouvoir est incroyable au delà de
tout ce que j'ai pu voir tout ce que
nous avons c'est le moment présent je
vous aime bien
j'ai attendu sans cet endroit rend tout
le monde un peu nerveux mais pas peur le
jeu est plus dangereux qu'il n'y paraît
toutes les difficultés que la terre a
connu ces 20 dernières années sont le
résultat de la guerre avec thierno sur
le point d'aller jouer au football avec
ce qui est en fait une bombe nucléaire
et tous
pense que c'est juste un jeu 6
c'est à peu près ça les plus faciles de
risquer sa vie quand on sait qu'on est
soutenue par des millions de personnes
même si elles ne connaissent pas la
vérité ou ne comprennent pas le risque
quatre jeunes terriens avec des pouvoirs
incroyables vous montrer qu'il existe
quelque chose qui peut les inspirer